foreign  [Music]  it's just like this Mafia at the top  does this man telling the truth I'm not  very optimistic about the future of the  West what do you think is gonna happen  and once you eat genetically modified  food they want to control everything  about us  I feel like a lot of times we judge  cultures that aren't our own sort of age  restricting things they started deleting  certain videos  you have to seek true through funny  that's my motto I'm a ginger you need  sunscreen no everyone gets like crazier  every five years right body shamer body  shamer everybody claps I grew up in The  Matrix do you feel like YouTube got you  out of it there's no consistency with  the morality this is just literally the  human embodiment of emotions over logic  we'll just stop being friends with yours  stop talking to you anybody so they  train you to be a slave they want you to  listen to woke people they want to take  away your brain  foreign